citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to complete season five Brooklyn
nine nine the momentous occasion don't
be to forget that's what I'm trying to
say leave a like on the video and
subscribe hit the notification Bell
thanks for prep for cutting these down
join us on patreon before we get to the
episode Greg has something to say yes
first off uh thank you guys so much for
being here and watching Brooklyn
Nine-Nine with us on this journey all
the way up to the end of season five you
guys rock so there's a couple of things
that I have to address I know in the
past that I've talked about yeah
Brooklyn nine nine per episode is not
exactly like the biggest performer for
us on this channel is that fact it can
be like really low sometimes but here's
the thing one of the ways you can factor
out if a show is actually being
successful for a YouTube channel like
ours is one I mean do we get a lot of
patrons from it and two do the views
increase leading to like returning
viewers or more viewership in the long
run blah blah blah stuff like that and
we have many many playlists on this
channel and every single month Brooklyn
nine nine is the second most viewed
playlist for the channel so I am
bringing that up to say it's a success
and we love the show so it's a win-win
in that department and I'm bringing that
up only because what I'm about to say
has nothing to do with view count or
money or anything of that regard it has
something to do with algorithm purposes
and that is because in the past few
weeks every single day starting all the
way up from season one to this latest
season one to three videos of Brooklyn
nine nine are getting blocked it keeps
at like literally a half hour before
filming another one got blocked we don't
really know what shift happened uh it's
been fine for so long we often have to
do several re-edits to get them
unblocked before we ever make them
public so we usually feel like they're
fine but lately it's just been a large
swarm of them it's getting to the point
where all of them are going to be bought
soon and that really really affects us
in the algorithm a copyright claim is
one thing but a block is a very negative
impact that's happening to the channel
so we wanted to make sure we at least
got to the the finish line here with
season five I'm saying all this because
sadly we're not sure if we can continue
this show it's all dependent on are we
able to defeat some of these blocks are
we able to beat some of these blocks if
we're not we really don't see the point
in committing the time for the editing
and all that it's really just TBD we
really don't know yet it's all dependent
on how how the progress goes with
removing some of these but we'll we'll
see I don't want to put a damper on the
mode because I I love this show John
loves this show and it is a success on
our Channel there might be a pause if we
end up deciding like okay this is
causing too many complications for us on
our end and it's affecting the channel
too much we will have to discontinue it
we might continue it just over at our
patreon because we do have a lot of
patrons who are there for the watch
alongs it's just something I had to
address I didn't want anyone to think
like me saying this had anything to do
with the views because like I said it's
our second we have many playlists and
our second most viewed playlist it's a
bummer if we have to stop I don't want
to stop it's just something that's we
just got to see how the progress goes
pretty much
anywho that's fun let's shift the mood
right now to just letting all that go
and just enjoying the final two episodes
of season five
and then we'll see if we'll be back for
season six we'll let you know on our
community page
I go into a coffee shop and as soon as
everybody sees that I'm a cop they stop
talking and they avoid eye contact with
me one lady even walked out I am just so
tired of being treated like the enemy
hey Hitchcock your penis is hanging out
what that's a relief
gonna say if we ever had a Hitchcock
cold open [__] penis hitch pen it's
penis penis backwards is Snip all right
there are seven days until the wedding
so you're officially transitioning from
the month of binder to
you know
finder oh yeah oh hell yeah hey Rosa why
do you have a picture of Sergio Navara
facial recognition picked him up at JFK
yesterday finally resurfaced after seven
years who's Sergio mendar the bane of my
existence Spain from Batman right that's
Yoda that's your Yoda impression you're
tracking him for weeks but he kept
getting away finally we cornered him in
a warehouse every exit was covered he
just vanished then he sent us a postcard
from Paraguay a year later just to
Thomas it was diabolical clever leak I'm
working this case with you absolutely we
have to do this he's your white whale
he's your Johnny Franzia the guy who's
been tormenting me with the deck of
cards for years looks like deuces are
wild Peralta seriously I feel like I
talk about him constantly sounds
familiar though you work the case and
hey he's gonna cool high five or
something I could
oh
if you need suggestions let me know good
ass handshake hello Raymond Olivia
we have a little bit of goop in your eye
oh thank you
I'm sorry to barge in like this wild
flight they're making their
recommendation to the mayor at the end
of next week John Kelly is going to beat
out both of us big shocker the straight
white man wins again take him down one
of us needs to step aside exactly you
should drop it is what you said to
yourself in the mirror this morning
instead of checking your eye for Goof
you should drop out is what you said to
yourself in the mirror this morning
while polishing your head what about his
first openly gay commissioner yes that
would be vital and important if you
weren't one million years old also I
come off quite beautiful you just said
huckster's crutch step aside Grandpa
[Music]
women will have their chance but it is
not this day I can see from your eyes
you're excited no way Sharon and the
girls are going on a play day all day
and I'm going to see a movie for
grown-ups no talking animals and tons of
cuss words always comes back to your
family breaking promises is how
marriages end not how they start how's
that going not well I'm already three
tasks behind and the alarms keep piling
up it's kind of making me a little bit
stressed
this is my life what he was to golf not
what he was to being a husband so his
husband game is Flawless but you owe me
yes anything you want now let's roll out
you freaking
yeah you piece of [__] according to this
picture from JFK he's taking the bus so
I'm guessing he's out of money in
Paraguay right didn't his number two say
he had to leave a bunch of his cash he's
baiting you that goes to Bed Stuy via
Garvey Avenue where he had a hideout in
Old Brownstone I don't know you think
he's dumb enough to go back there yeah I
do because he forgot who was on his tail
nope he remembered oh no
is this guy always one step ahead of us
God I hate him
no God
ow my Noggin okay fine let's just write
the exact same quotes clearly you've
never seen me with the elderly they love
me I could talk about coupons for days
son that's right you're looking at a
senior Queen what is that that's not a
widely used term yes senior Queen words
have no more meaning Terry we're running
out of time man you got to make a call
but what if I choose wrong I mean that's
a terrible way to start off a marriage
people won't even watch our first dance
they're going to be too busy
overthinking you know the right napkin
this is this worse with that crimping no
way oh my God what did I just do yes I
haven't got my groom gut every groom has
groomed gut it is
oh Jacob classy but very absorbent
simple and it won't clash with our color
scheme it's perfect we'll take it
Gina and I have been discussing the
situation and we think we know what you
need to do well what is that whisper
campaign it's the best way to bring down
an enemy if you don't want to get your
hands dirty
there has to be another way there is
sir Louise mendar was right over there
officers oh please don't call us that
we're Undercover the elderly are
Treasures to society actually from
experience she is more right you
definitely shouldn't be working here in
fact your elders sir I thought we could
do an oral history project on your
family wouldn't that be a hoot oh I
guess so well I was born during the
Depression and I had to sleep in a
dresser drawer till I was three Yep this
is more of a recent history like
I don't have any relatives except for my
grandson who I haven't seen in seven
years are you going to see him soon how
do I know we had a chamber Bank not now
Eunice
do you think planning a funeral I want
dahlias
no no no Brown sprinkles at the ice
cream bar do you think I'm planning a
funeral it's the chocolate but Rainbow's
great too why do you keep saying the
funeral thing because my groom gut has a
catchphrase boy
starts look at this I cleared all my
alarms oh no he he messed something up
I'm the one who let him get away the
first time when we had him cornered in
that warehouse you told me to cover the
back I always wondered how he got away I
let him it was my fault and I never told
you kill her whoa
maybe definitely let's go
that seems like a good thing why isn't
she happier there's a lot going on and I
can't explain Ezra you save the day
[Music]
Louise is in on it she knows what's up
following an old lady about to catch her
white whale so the name I just came up
with if you like it stay silent
good I like it too that's our name
forever oh
Blue Sisters
if I saw anything peculiar there's a
very strange man in Louisa's room
digging around while she's away yes
yes can I put you on hold it is peculiar
I bet that's Sergio I bet he set up this
whole Louise thing as a distraction to
get us out of the nursing home Pew your
man was Sergio Eunice what did the man
smell like like an English garden oh
that said actually came into play we're
drinking the wine with the foot on the
label but it's a huge savings and we can
make up the rest we just assemble the
gift bags ourselves okay we can do that
how much work love the purple on him hey
Hitchcock and Scully how would you two
like to earn some candy almonds water
bottle not a shorbing local Jam they can
Amy cookies
politics is the right motivation sir
Olivia Crawford is on her way up I know
I invited her did you change your mind
about the whispering because we came up
with some dandies I
oh
dropping out I wasn't considering what's
best for this city I sent a letter
withdrawing my name from the
commissioner's race I've been waiting my
entire career for a commissioner like
you if I have to be the bigger person to
open the doors to change that I also
felt bad and I also said
[Music]
no that's on Kelly are you too old to
run are you too inexperienced to know
that power walking is a far more
efficient and sustainable method of
hurrying burn
uh aloe vera on that Hitchcock and
Scully did more than I did yeah but you
had to hold your hand near their mouths
when you fed them those almonds all
right let's get
let's get God damn it oh but then I had
to sneeze and I thought I don't want to
sneeze on these keys but it should be do
not sneeze on my keys do not wheeze off
do not sneeze on your knees on my keys
if you please get tarot okay so then I
put them on top of a plastic tub which
is locked inside the car
these are locked inside the car
hi it's Eunice the lady with the
chamberman yes Eunice we know who you
are that man is in the hole right now oh
Eunice you're on the ground what you're
you're mine whoa
yes very easily
oh it'd be like paralyzed you had an
instinct you followed and you were wrong
that happens to everybody you kept it
away he really lied to me we didn't know
each other well back then when I first
got to the 99 I was a little intimidated
by you
a nurse who hates old people Ezra of
course never leave your money
unprotected that's the first thing I
learned in Business Schools also went to
business school yeah and I also have a
pilot's license whatever point is I'm
gonna reset your knee look at the money
huh
I called the locksmith he said now that
means two hours minimum we can't wait
that long our little cookie faces are
already melting we look like to do the
thing Harry the dealer tried charging me
an extra 300 for it I told him I didn't
want it because Terry never loses his
key yeah but Jake does you always have
to plan around me I'm a partier
these tasks were a way for me to prove I
was going to be a good husband and I
failed Jake being a good husband doesn't
mean you have to pass some tests or do
everything right do you have any
I often I mess things up so you're a bad
husband too
you've been doing everything possible to
make sure Amy was happy you keep doing
that you're gonna be okay even if you
make some mistakes hey yeah yeah what
the hell my man what are you doing
whatever it takes to make Amy happy you
told me to do this now let's
dude
hey Diego we're gonna take each other's
names oh my God
it's coming out of your paycheck the
white number 10. it's the same kind you
use to send fan mail to yourself I've
never done that but I do know what
envelopes my fans use so that's very
helpful
yes well done Olivia tear that up and
now we just have to find your letter
what are the dimensions of your envelope
Zero by zero it's too late for me I
withdrew from the race by email yes I
use email because I'm not a million
years old
someone has to beat John Kelly so you
better get that damn job because I'm
excited to have you as my commissioner
and I'll be excited for you to be
commissioner after me that'll probably
be in a matter of months once you die
from old age you don't need to keep hey
you have a minute I'm actually kind of
busy right now right harboring a
fugitive should I come back
yeah Amy was ready get him
get him
clotheslined Sergio mendar you're under
arrest I can't believe you caught me
we'll believe it we're an amazing team
for the sleuth sisters how great we are
slew sisters lame stay out of Sergio
you're lame Sergio
you're alone handling text before this
goes it's all good you're ready gang
we're gonna begin the next episode in
three yep two what
three two one
can't believe this is a Rec Center it
looks amazing you look amazing foxy as
hell simmer down boy no no I love it
Ames you look beautiful but what are you
getting your makeup put on y'all she
woke up like this
Harry Rosa will you please take this
Veil to a dry cleaner and if they won't
do a rush job make them I mean we're not
going to abuse our power of course not
we're good cops I was not exaggerating
okay now for that's why we're in the
world where we live in now what about my
allergies I got your meds right here I
brought them just in case Hitchcock
decided to wear his toupee again it's
very clearly not human hair human hair
oh count on us flat topping the freak we
always
not in any way shape or form but it's a
very stressful day and I thought things
would go better without Hitchcock and
Scully we planned a great wedding yeah
their other band yes there's an arm at
your wedding it said to explode at 5 30.
so
that was not the gay guy oh hardcore
it's gonna be some jigsaw [__] at the
wedding I thought it was just a black
guy it's definitely just a really deep
voiced black guy it's Terry's
brother-in-law or whatever
we should leave who would do something
like this well I clearly have an arch
nemesis must be someone I put away who's
hell-bent on Revenge he's probably gonna
make me choose between saving the city
and saving the woman I love
if you're trying to kill someone you
don't call and give them a heads up so
they're just trying to scare us yeah but
it doesn't matter the bomb squad's on
their way they'll do a quick sweep find
nothing and split and this will just
become a funny story we work into our
best Teddy I'm in location of the
ceremony Amy very careful about throwing
around accusations like that because if
you're trying to say I somehow ruined
Jake's wedding then I'm gonna kill
myself so Trent
bomb squad is already here and they
brought a robot this is
wedding would be when I was a kid I have
a job to do and I'm gonna do it
professionally this is great I'm happy
to hear that meaning I will be doing a
super thorough sweeping at the building
it's going to take hours so you should
probably just cancel the wedding anyway
congrats you two oh there's not a real
bomb yeah he planned this people how
many siblings they have oh is it
somewhere between zero and two how
fascinating but you never know when
you're gonna find your dream person
anyone on the street could be that all
right it feels what about that girl at
the bar you can close yourself off all
you want the universe will find a way
that is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard hi I'm here to pick up Rose then
oh you know what I'm looking for
hey she's famous
so Rosa only dates women now I guess so
yeah just got an email from the mayor's
office telling me if I'm the next
commissioner of the NYPD well
finally something to care about today
each building but there's not really a
bomb so it's just temporary what about
you guys did you get the veil Terry has
it
I do oh no I left it in the car dumbass
I'll just call the company and bring her
back here and then wait a minute did you
do this intentionally so I'd have to see
that girl again no that's that's crazy
don't worry about them let's go check on
Teddy I'm sure he's made a ton of
progress nope I haven't even gone in yet
still putting on the bomb suit yeah my
job is super dangerous but I like living
life on the edge just kind of sexy if
you think about it the Ted Locker it's
life it's sometimes the unlikeliest
outcome it feels like you're winding up
to propose again here I was good
catching Amy
I knew that you would so I came prepared
nicotine patches you just put it on your
shoulder and whoop stuck it right on
your face huh one as close to my brain
as possible third eye three hours to
save this wedding it's good I love you
so much I love you too wait you're
talking to the nicotine R2
[Music]
I can love two things
it was a burner but they caught it
pinging off a cell tower in Fort Greene
one block away from the last known
address of Frank Gillespie just because
you arrested him well we didn't have
enough evidence against him at first so
let's just say I had to get a little
creative oh Jesus I went undercover and
became best friends with him and then he
told me about his lymphoma and we ran a
10K together and
great let's go talk to him that must be
our guy hey great attitude Ames you're
handling this really well oh there they
are all right
like when people go cupping ignore him
we left a dry cleaning bag in your back
seat oh I didn't see anything but you
could take a look the veil's not here
Rosa was so
oh
hell yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
hell yeah yeah
Frozen what the hell are you doing what
you were the one that said that was
before the bear went missing when life
was breathing
why is this so heavy oh it will be again
I simply want everyone to focus on the
bride and groom and not on whether my
lifelong dream which I spent decades
working towards has collapsed in front
of my eyes leaving me untethered in this
world and unsure of my very future with
the NYPD
you think he has a shrine of photos of
me with the eyes scratched out unless
that rule out the very real possibility
that it's entirely sexual oh man that
would be super upsetting and so cool
okay okay put the lotion in the basket
is there a problem we're looking for
Frank Gillespie he died a year ago what
what happened well his lymphoma came
back but really yeah it was the
loneliness that killed him somebody
heard him and he just couldn't make
friends yet
huh
do you remember Dario Moretti that money
launderer I arrested he lives right
around here too so he hated me I'm not
involved in this at all I mean you hear
yourself right
check out your guy and I'll be totally
fine with it if it's him oh man whoa
even the eyes are all scratched out babe
when we're married we're going to share
everything Kyle Gas where is Teddy hi
Jakey and Linda what are you doing here
how'd you get past the police barricade
well I moved them
I hated detective Santiago since she
arrested me and then I saw that
engagement announcement in the paper but
you could have figured out where the
wedding was even without that right no I
was trying I had totally given up really
I'm not gonna just take this guy's word
for it that there's no bomb why not he's
the one who would know so you think a
cop should just stop what they're doing
as soon as a criminal tells them they
didn't do it oh my God that is actually
a really good point yeah clearly in
Hollywood also quit vibing and help me
solve this sorry man that's what the
universe wants screw the universe the
universe is a spooniverse everything
inside is totally nope soaked in urine
damn it Who You Are
Jesus
Jesus I want this job jeopardize my
relationship with Kevin and now to find
out if it was all in vain there's a lot
on the line agreed let's just grab
chatter and go to the wedding where is
he oh no
he's eating the cake oh he ate the cake
oh cheddar you furry little pig oh this
is terrible he can't add that too
there's chocolate on it this is all my
fault I put the announcement in the
paper and ruined this day but now I'm
gonna be the one to fix it get rid of
you two I'm about to save this
did you say there was no bomb because I
wanted to kill Amy then why did you call
him the threat I didn't my daughter
found my hidden room and discovered some
blueprints yes yes fine Teddy you were
right killing it Teddy evacuate this
entire block is going to take all night
wait so you're saying weddings off for
real it's over Jakey what's this that I
hear that there's no rap
marry you on top of the Empire State
Building that sounds kind of during a
King Kong attack oh yeah that's not good
let's do them all you're getting married
right here right now what come on Boyle
I don't even have a dress you could wear
genus I'm sure it's white there's no way
Gina was going to wear a white dress to
my wedding no I definitely was what yep
Jake and Amy are getting married tonight
title of my sex tape what whoa whoa wait
I gotta look forward
that was Gina's dress yep I know I
ruined your bear but I made you a new
one it's a shower curtain uh yep Terry
fumbled to task oh it's wedding time
so here it is oh my God only in shows
City resources this would take at least
an hour and a half to set up it's
beautiful how can I ever repay you get
pregnant
away from you now I will see you up
there
and get pregnant
[Music]
guitar this
hey Malibus I don't know you
okay
[Music]
first of all the wedding guests there's
somebody the cops we are here today to
celebrate the marriage of Jake Peralta
and Amy Santiago hell yeah
has been a true pleasure to watch your
distracting childish rivalry evolve into
a distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage
I think it's I think it's been more than
five years and I love you both what
you captain oh also yesterday and the
day before that and the day before that
and every other day and you Jake Peralta
are the right person for me
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt your butt is the bomb
there will be no survivors
that butt
I love you so much
spend the rest of my life with you
please bring the Rings but I thought
cheddar was sick oh my God you got the
robot oh
that's awesome take Amy Santiago to be
your wife I absolutely do
by the power
you may kiss a bride
well done kids
yes
not everything is in our control but as
long as we're with the right people we
can handle anything
so I'd like to receive this news the
hell said that
well I'm from the look on my face I'm
sure you can guess what it says
yep no we at all just tell us you
monster
goddess the cliff hang
wow they gotta work out the Kinks yeah I
gotta figure out if this will work or
not in the writer's room
but the answer is closer to the premiere
wowie we did it we caught the white
whale we got married everything went
wrong but everything went right this is
a very Charming Duo of episodes and who
was it that played Rose's new love
interest the Jane the Virgin girl yeah
what's her name
why don't you just type in Jane the
Virgin Jane's version is an easier
search Gina Rodriguez yeah go there you
go
very sure it was her
pretty sure
[Music]
I'm pretty sure
yeah that's her that's definitely her
are you sure we're not just being racist
all right Gina Rodriguez what if it says
like Brooklyn nine nine she's been in
like six seasons
yes she's she's with her all right it
was her it's right that they got married
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes Miss Bala herself dude what did you
think of these two episodes
as a married man you are the best person
to comment I love the napkin part the
best part of all of the episodes
best part groom gut
get back groom gut my groom gut did not
cooperate with me on my wedding
no
no nope
it's cool calm collected
I was I was great at my wedding that was
really calm yeah
she was freaking out you are unfair I
was like
why I'm tired everything's gonna be
roughly the same after this skip is now
it'll be official so we can eat food
yeah I'm very tired
yeah so we can go on to a very pleasant
and uninterrupted evening of partying
yeah okay so I can relate to a wedding
gone wrong um I'll tell you guys uh
might as well
so I ordered uh we ordered a Beyond taco
truck because we don't eat meat we
ordered a vegetarian taco truck
specifically beyond meat and and then uh
but the ending of my vows was actually
uh now let's go eat some [__] food
like that's what I said it wasn't in my
vows uh immediately went to go get food
and then within about 15 minutes I
started noticing like oh I can't
maintain this conversation with this
individual I'm having right now because
I'm clearly having some type of response
to this food that is not boating well
for me so I'm just gonna like uh be like
yeah
and then uh 10 minutes later I'm on the
floor in the bathroom and my face is
purple my eyes are bloodshot red and my
chest is an excruciating pain and I've
never felt an allergic reaction like
this in my life I am really really sick
and I can't handle it and instantly
asked Olivia to go ask the Beyond taco
truck people if they I'm not naming who
they are
um
there's not many out there in Colorado
though just let you guys know that and
then uh
[Music]
um sure but I I asked them because their
menu says be on taco truck but I am
fully aware I am allergic to the other
fake meat product which is impossible
meat I am 100 aware I am allergic to
that so I immediately asked can you see
if they serve me impossible meaning not
be on me
sure enough they serve me impossible me
and I just scarfed down a bunch of it
and uh
uh I did not want to draw attention to
myself but then once it got to the point
where it was like okay I have to sneak
out of here and I'm not gonna be able to
be at my wedding for a while because I
gotta go to the Urgent Care
so brother-in-law took me and I was away
from the wedding and made it back for
the last hour and a half
yep
all drugged up I told the the doctor
like give me whatever you can so I can
function and catch me up Duck yep and so
I missed out uh most of my wedding V and
here's the best part that comp those
people took no responsibility and they
did not even say I am sorry not one
point point did they say I'm sorry their
menu everyone took photos said beyond
meat on it
the the a lot of people confronted them
no one ended up eating after that so
thousands of dollars like a political
statement grab any food off the table
Yeah so a lot of money I spent that no
one touched and they did refuse to even
take the slightest bit of accountability
they said we didn't know you were
allergic
didn't matter I said why should I tell
you that you're and if you're
advertising a brand new name alternative
then maybe you should have it be that
particular thing or announce when it's
different yeah it says Beyond me
everyone took photos now one thing said
impossible me
and so yeah missed out on a good portion
of that let me know what happened right
your arch enemy got to the truck people
first and rigged it
I think it was John's gift to my wedding
yes I was like you know what this dude
I'm gonna level up to the nicer meat I
guess maybe and uh yeah
so Charles boiled it that was uh so I
relate with the wedding gone wrong I do
love in movies and shows specifically
shows when the weddings go wrong they're
always like let's just it doesn't matter
we don't want to build a new set let's
just use the sets we already have
they're just like we want to it's just
about us it's not our love
let's do it and then they put together
like something that looks even more
romantic yeah than the streets I love
that Trope yeah it's cute it's cute it's
charming and uh it was a fun episode I
love what they've done with Teddy he's a
sketch yeah yeah I like the just the way
that he grows each time he's always
pathetic but he's always on flap of liso
and uh and I like that they I like that
they misled us with that but of course
he would show up you get a little Kyle
Gas Tenacious D Cameo real bomb I
thought that was also kind of a nice
touch it's like oh damn this this is a
real situation because it's like it's
such a light episode that's easy to
forget like oh somebody just did an act
of terrorist yeah
um but yeah and all the various
Adventures very fun uh also the sleuth
sisters in the previous episode was a
nice touch bruttle me this what what do
you got
they had to spend a long time to get the
bomb out how was Teddy at the wedding
oh yeah he said it would take all night
maybe they just left the ball
Teddy was like I'll get to this later
because uh what is it they need a half
hour to get the the wedding set up so
yeah it doesn't track man it doesn't
track doesn't track mathematically it's
not proportionate yeah plus it probably
costs like fifteen thousand dollars just
to wheel that robot down the aisle for
like why didn't they invite the people
to the wedding who were supposed to go
yeah I know there were like random New
Yorkers there there could have been Aunt
uh what's her name Linda What Becomes of
all the food
oh
goes to the homeless is it right that
the cops were sectioning off an entire
Street
for a wedding that you would probably
need a permit to pull something so it's
a legal wedding that they pulled off to
they abused their power
and they pulled uh resources in the form
of both the uniformed officers and
police cruisers to block the area I mean
just that process alone would take a
half hour that all 28 minutes yeah
well you know I'm sure he delegated a
few tasks
because uh
I'm sure pretty much Terry helped out
and and Rosa helped out that's my theory
is Gina would be useless uh Hitchcock is
gully were off finding malignos hold his
you know
maybe he helped a little bit Yeah but
yeah it would have to be Rose she
probably strong-armed the permits Terry
probably did a lot of the physical
setting stuff up and Boyle probably just
delegated I mean this is a big uh
shenanigan Fest of what can go wrong
will go wrong and and that was very pure
Brooklyn Nine-Nine style and I really
really enjoyed it the white whale one
was okay but I really love the the
finale yeah yeah absolutely it was a
nice little bonding experiment for Amy
and Rosa but even that episode is half
about the wedding impending and then
this is the payoff to that so real like
yeah the the sluice sisters is a bit of
the ringer plot line stupid Charles damn
it Charles
how would you do that
teacher because he wanted everyone in
New York to show up because he knows how
much of a hero Jake is to the citizens
they're not Reid Richardson has a
terrible idea man yeah
I mean it's a bad idea when you read
Richardson Sue storm too but you know
worse worse when you're a cop I feel
like especially in the world that we
live in
um but the groom getting involved like
that nah no no we're near that level of
involvement of mine but I like seeing
Jake all excited get all lovey-dovey
here feels like Amy was uh not that
involved with the wedding stuff these
last couple episodes I know like the
actual wedding stuff I feel like they
still at least it seems like she would
have I mean I know the thing with Rosa
was important but it feels like nothing
would pull her away from wedding
planning yeah you know or or I don't
know yeah even in this episode we don't
really see that much of it which is an
interesting thing actually it would have
been kind of interesting to see from the
bride's side rather than mostly the
grooms
but you know
can't do an hour-long finale
I suppose they could have
40 minutes 44 minutes they could have
done that yeah they could have done a
whole I mean if they had done that it
would have been really hard to tell
where stuff was gonna go I don't know it
was sweet cute and funny but at the same
time this doesn't really look that big
of an impact for some reason
I mean it's the part of it that I've
been to uh hesitant to say but the more
I talk about it the more I'm like yeah
I'm not really living much it's not a
strong impression surprisingly it's very
sweet and charming and especially so in
the moment however I mean you can kind
of predict a lot of what goes down I
mean you can kind of assume
that it will end up the way it ends up
yeah you know so it's like well executed
but also not much in the way of like the
only big surprise to me was that there
was an actual bomb sort of I like to
Halt saying he loves them yeah that was
very sweet and and his vow like his uh
officiating in general was a nice thing
duh
that cliffhanger
I'm wrapped I like to I don't know if
we'll see Allison Tolman again as Olivia
what's her name but I I liked oh yeah
yeah that was great yeah and uh and I
thought the way that ended up actually
was kind of fun and unexpected because
uh you know you you could see it coming
that they both would withdraw but the
actual machination there was like that's
that's fun and clever I like that
what you think of Rosa and Amy taking
down the white whale
it's pretty you know I mean it was fun I
had a fun time with it and I like seeing
them together as the sleuth sisters and
in a you know I mean like that's usually
the kind of plotline that like a jake
character would have so I liked seeing
them to take it on sure and uh
I like I like the joke that Rosa has all
this background that we have no idea
about oh yeah business that's cool I
think that that building block has been
consistently funny yes and it seems to
line up for some reason
you kind of like Creed from the office
but respectable sure yeah instead of the
most depraved things it's just like oh
really like that's impressive yeah like
Rosa is just so impressive and so
multifaceted and yeah it is like a gift
that keeps on giving joke because it
also works both ways I mean like you
know sometimes it's about how just
unbelievably tough and badass she is so
like her going to use force on uh the
the veil people tracks uh but at the
same time yeah her
having again like three years of med
school like is yes it's a it's well
drawn because you can use it for uh both
purposes which is nice rather than just
one particular game I like how that she
they're real she's bisexual and it's
just constantly only woman that's what
it means
it's just you have dated men before the
relationships whole relationship with
someone for a while only pursuing women
only trying to get hooked up with women
it's all all women they keep saying
you're bisexual
and it's just funny I get it I guess
like uh she's exploring that obvious way
to denote that yeah
um
I was like what they should we ever see
or dated another guy again or is the
show gonna go like nah only woman now
I feel like they're going only one going
that way because
yeah it's weird I feel like if they care
about the bisexual Representatives yeah
I guess it would make more sense to not
just de facto her into being a lesbian
oh solely yeah uh yeah I don't know
we'll see maybe Nick Cannon will come
back either maybe she'll spark yeah
maybe she'll bring back the old Sparkle
pimento
doubt it but it'd be nice to see him
again he wasn't at the wedding he wasn't
oh my God
that didn't make sense
sometime and I mean I don't know Gina
Rodriguez is like enough of a enough of
a face that I'm like are we gonna see
her again is she gonna become involved
in some way shape or form it seems like
any character that isn't directly
working at the precinct is not someone
you're apt to really see much of but at
the same time I'm like they did go out
is it just finale stunt casting of like
ah we got a celebrity in here or is that
building up to like no no we're gonna
bring her into the cast for a minute
it would be cool if they did that at
least because too I mean it's it's sort
of like
is Rosa dating who's Rose dating she
dating
like it'd be cool to maybe see a
relationship actually
happen with her and explore that a
little bit that would be nice
[Music]
but yeah it was a Charming pair of
episodes Amen brother nice little bow on
the season maybe not the most surprising
Journey but a very lovely one at that uh
so guys what's your favorite uh
on-screen wedding
to let us know and what's your uh what
would your dream wedding be
and uh are you married are you ever
gonna get married what would you pick
out for all the things on Jake's
whiteboard comment it below every single
question I want an answer to got
anything else to tell the people
um
no if this is the last one then
haha
you always your time it's never gonna be
ended or maybe it will now let's see
what happens I hope it goes we we have
literally like 30 blocked videos in the
last week and it's ridiculous it's it's
a lot of blog videos guys who's bored
over it yeah the universe just keeps
every day it's manually going through
and being like nope hiling every day and
I'm like why don't you just block them
all let's just blocked like it doesn't
even make any sense no you guys are hurt
it's like on you right now and
something's wrong with episode three of
season one is uh I watched every one of
these episode nine is wrong I sat there
and I marked the time stamps
footage appears like this is like a
random assortment of [__] picking and
choosing of what's okay and what is it
just makes no sense to me yeah yeah but
it's important work yeah yeah so if you
see this manual claimer just know know
that you're a hero yeah and this job
that you're doing right now is really
impacting the studio in a big way you
know you gotta put for other table
that's right
I guess if we were looked at as people
who promoted the studios the studios are
just letters I guess that's true and now
they're hurting so they're like well
you're not giving us any promos so we're
just gonna take whatever you get from
Mario said you don't promote so you know
it's every episode of Brooklyn 99 we
didn't like
yeah
I'm sure that's the case because there
have been so many ones we've hated
anyway guys hopefully see you for more
being nine nine but if not thank you for
making this thank you for the journey a
lovely Journey
Die Hard
[Music]